>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: All right
everyone get your coffee, settle in.
I'm glad to see most of you back
here today for the second day
of our symposium; Collections,
Collaborations and Connections.
I think we had a fabulous day.
I know the staff felt very
good yesterday about a lot
of the discussion and I'm really
thrilled to see so many people kind
of connecting, meeting each other.
Researchers talking with archivists.
Imagine. So, we've got
another fabulous day.
Again, I think focusing
on our collections
and in particular we're
going to be really zeroing
in on the wax cylinder collections
of Native American material.
And you'll be meeting
some of the partners
that we're working with these days.
And I think going to find out
about a really exciting project,
a development that I
think in some ways kind
of brings the federal
cylinder project,
which a few people
referenced yesterday,
brings it into the 21st-century.
But before we do that, we're
going to hear a little bit more
about the wax cylinder
collections from Judith Gray,
our senior reference specialist.
Judith.
[ Applause ]
>> Judith Gray: Good morning
and welcome to all of you.
Actually, I'm taking as my role,
to set the stage even broader
for what the center has been about.
What the library has been about with
its Native American collections.
I started looking back and realized
that probably the very earliest
field recordings that we received
that are tribal based came in
July1936 when Helen Roberts;
Helen Heffron Roberts gave
the library disk copies
of her Luiseño cylinder
recordings that she had made
in Pechanga, California in 1926.
So, interestingly enough, the first
part of this whole discussion has
to do with migrating of formats.
And so, the very first
recordings, field recordings,
that we received here were
already a migrated format.
She gave us the disc copies,
rather than the cylinders.
Although the cylinders
themselves came later.
We then go three years later, when
Willard Rhodes, a music professor
at Columbia University started
about a 15-year project.
He had been hired by the
Bureau of Indian Affairs to go
out in the summers and to record
contemporary native song traditions.
And he went all over the US in
different years and collected many,
many, many disc recordings
all through the 40s.
While the recordings
were made for the Bureau
of Indian affairs there was
some sort of an agreement
that they would be
promptly deposited
in the Library of Congress.
They are some of the most; some
of the best audio quality ones
that we have that are
early in that period.
Then we have 1942, a rather
interesting year as it turns out.
Smack in the middle of World War II.
But it was in that year in April
when Alan Lomax recorded
the Isleta Pueblo here
in the library's recording studio.
All through the decades and such,
many of the early cylinder
recordings were actually made here
in Washington DC, when people
from visiting delegations
were recorded here.
And in fact, I believe we are
essentially directly over the place
where many early recordings
were made.
Alice Fletcher had a townhouse,
in this block on the side
of the street back in the 1890s.
And she recorded a great many
people visiting at that point.
So, I think the cylinders which were
here, went elsewhere, and elsewhere,
and elsewhere have come
back home essentially.
But we didn't get those
cylinders themselves
until significantly later.
But back then, to 1942, so,
April was when these Isleta
Pueblo governor was recorded.
In September, the library had
already begun releasing sampler
albums of recordings
in its collections.
And in that year, the
predecessor of this;
this is this is the LP version,
but it would've been six 78s
in an album, were released.
The collection of William Fenton,
"Song from The Iroquois
Longhouse" recorded both
in New York and in Canada.
The project, or the recordings
themselves were made in 1941.
And that particular recording
project was sponsored by the Bureau
of American Ethnology and
the Library of Congress.
So, the library was already starting
to gather tribal recordings
at that point.
That same summer, a woman named
Henrietta Yurchenco documented
Tarascan and mestizo music
in Michoacán, Mexico.
Those recordings, which came here,
the Tarascan ones are perhaps
the first non US field recordings
of indigenous people that came here.
While that particular
project of hers was not done
in direct consultation, or
collaboration, with the library;
her subsequent projects from 1944 to
1946 were sponsored by the Institute
of [speaking in foreign language],
and the Library of Congress.
And in those years, she gathered
documentation of Cora, Huichol,
Seri, Yaqui, Tarahumara,
Tzotzil, and Tzeltal songs.
Then we get to 1948.
One of the most significant
collectors of field recordings up to
that point for the Bureau
of American Ethnology was a
woman named Francis Densmore.
The recordings; her
cylinder recordings and those
of many others made for the
BAE had been transferred
to the National Archives around
the beginning of the decade.
But Densmore really had hopes.
She knew about the
sampler disk publications
at the library was releasing.
She managed to pull enough strings
and to influence enough people
that it was at that point, 1948,
when all of those early BAE
cylinder recordings were transferred
to the library in her hope there
was that she would then be able
to make the sampler
recordings of the same sort
that Fenton and others had done.
To make those recordings
available in that case,
principally to educators, composers.
She wanted the music,
the music of America
to be more broadly
heard and understood.
It was not however, project aimed
at returning materials
back to tribal communities.
This was definitely
outreach to other areas.
So, after that, for the next
couple of decades, certainly,
the library was receiving
collections
that were tribally based.
Materials then were being
copied, but they were being copied
by audio engineers who would've
had no particular knowledge
of what traditions
they were working with.
They would've had no
particular documentation.
So, it was sort of blind copying
and sometimes that resulted
in things being copied
at incorrect speeds.
Sometimes incorrect names
being applied to collections.
But it was an ongoing process.
We then jump to 1976,
and the creation
of the American Folklife Center.
And you've heard a lot about the
field projects that were underway
as soon as the center was created.
But also, at that point,
an early outreach project,
the Federal Cylinder Project.
And, well I came on in 1983,
just at the time when a lot
of the original cataloging and
preservation had been done.
And when people were
starting to actually get
into the process of dissemination.
We got all sorts of good
advice on how to do this,
how to make this happen
from various tribal experts.
And in all we probably visited
at least 50 communities.
We sent materials to others.
And at that point I was
guesstimating that in the course
of any particular year, we were
in touch with representatives
from at least 70 different
communities.
The big profit project though
was with the Omaha tribe.
And here, both Alan Jabbour and Carl
Fleischhauer had a big hand working
directly with the tribe.
Going back and forth, bringing
tribal representatives,
especially the tribal historian,
Dennis Hastings, here to DC.
And going, having people going out
and documenting the annual
powwows in Macy, Nebraska.
So, that interchange, but that
was then definitely designed
to return materials
to the communities,
to the community of
origin in this case.
So, in trying to set this up for
what you're going to be hearing
about FCP 2.0, as I've
been hearing it called.
At that point then, through
the original cylinder project,
we were working very
much sort of outreach
from here to the communities.
And trying to find
out what they needed,
trying to provide technical
assistance,
trying to provide the
materials themselves.
But then, I think things
sort of shifted.
At that point, into the
90s and more recently,
it's been much more a
process of collaboration,
and a process of having people
decide when they need water from us.
We can provide whatever they
are asking for, but it comes,
the initiation of most of
these projects since then,
has come from the tribes
themselves, from the communities,
from individuals who
are the culture keepers.
And meanwhile, what we've
been doing is having more
and more collaborations with
the National Park Service
on the historic preservation
grants to tribes with keepers
of the treasures, was
another aspect of that.
You heard yesterday
about Breath of Life.
Many more partnerships being
established between agencies,
between archives and
between communities
where the materials belong.
And it is that which is so exciting
to hear about the next project.
So, with that, I turn
it over to you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: So,
while; hi I'm Guha Shankar,
good morning, thank you for coming.
While I have Judith here, I
thought I would do something
that just gives me great pleasure.
I think it will provide
you with some insight
into the work that she does.
I have a visual aid.
This is somewhat bedraggled
bag, it's from the Association
of Tribal Archives
Libraries and Museums,
which is an organization dedicated
to bringing together professionals
from across indigenous
communities around the world,
every year in an annual conference.
Now ATALM every year
starting in 2007, identifies
and recognizes organizations
and individuals who serve
as outstanding examples of how
individuals archives, libraries,
museums, and individuals
contribute to the vitality
and cultural sovereignty
of native nations.
The guardian award which
they give out, takes its name
from the sculpture that stands
atop the Oklahoma State Capitol,
and honors the words of the
seminal Chief Kelly Haney, who said,
"Dream big, work hard,
believe deeply
for this is just the beginning.
To that end, we have
two former winners right
up here on stage with us.
In 2012, Kim Christen,
here, took home the award
for the Plateau People's
Portal, web portal.
An interactive online digital
archive that provides access
to Plateau people's
culture and materials
at Washington State University
through tribal curation.
And you'll hear more
about all aspects
of that a little later
in this presentation.
Last year, Donald Soctomah,
to my far left,
won the Lifetime Achievement
Award for his work
of significantly contributing
to preservation understanding
of indigenous cultural heritage.
So, former winners.
[ Applause ]
And in 2016, when all of you
I'm sure are going to be at the
on Tuesday, October 11 at the
Sheraton Grande Wild Horse resort
and spa, you will be there
obviously for the honoring ceremony
for our very own, Dr. Judith Gray,
who has won the 2016 Honored
One Award from the Association
of Tribal Archives
Libraries and Museums.
[ Applause ]
>> Judith Gray: I was floored.
I got the word yesterday.
So, thank you to all
and but it's you know,
in being honored this way
it's honoring the archives
and the work we do.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: All right, so.
Now, to the panel at hand.
And I'm going to spare
you the details
of these distinguished
individuals' bios.
You have them online, I'm sure
you've consulted them eagerly
over the course of
the last week or so.
But starting to my
right Donald Soctomah,
from Passamaquoddy Nation in Maine.
James Francis from Penobscot
Nation of Maine also.
Jane Anderson from New York
University and founder and developer
of the Traditional Knowledge Labels
through localcontext.org,
which you'll hear about.
And, the aforementioned
Kim Christen who is
from Washington State University
and the conceptual genius behind the
lucrative contact management system.
So. Sorry, it's early in the
morning, I've had too much coffee.
So, I'm going to turn it over
to them basically to tell you
about this project that we've
initiated called Ancestral Voices.
It's a project that we
started as a pilot project
with the Passamaquoddy
Nation of Maine.
We initiated it about, we
actually developed the program
about four years ago under the
behest of the former Library
of Congress, Dr. James Billington.
And we've carried that through
in partnership with the very fine
and expert staff at the National
Audiovisual Conservation Center
out in Culpeper, Virginia.
The audio engineers have
been working assiduously
on the collection of Jesse Walter
Fuchs is 1890 field recordings
of Passamaquoddy people.
We have, you know, taken
at least the second pass
on this particular set of materials,
but 20th-century technology
yielded reel to reel cassette,
reel to reel tapes and cassettes.
We have now gone back
and transferred those materials
using cutting edge tools in order
to bring it into the digital domain.
And you will hear an example of that
when Donald speaks a little
later in the presentation.
This is a collaborative preservation
digitization and access project,
which consists essentially of,
the central aspects involved,
digitally reformatting analog
media formats in order to recover
and preserve the recorded
voices of native peoples.
To be developed curatorial protocols
that address community
cultural practices
and perspectives regarding use and
access to new cultural materials,
as well as digital access tools
that embed Native American cultural
knowledge about and descriptions
of the content of recordings
and library collection
records to the extent possible.
I'm going to shoot forgo for now
that we're talking about the work
that the library has done in
terms of digitization materials,
but to tell you a little
bit about the technology
and have these folks explain
in their own words what the digital
tools enable us to do in terms
of providing an interface
between the library archives
such as ourselves,
and native peoples.
Without necessarily calling into
question our own methodologies.
It must be said that there's
a certain amount of agility
which external parties can employ
in terms of digital technologies
which the library, for many
reasons is not able to do.
Not for lack of trying.
But that's just the way
the technology works
to a certain extent.
And one of the things
which is amazing to me,
is that of all the resources of
the library are brought to bear
on projects such as this,
as you know, as Lyntha
and Terry Eiler were
saying yesterday,
these materials have
been lying around,
and to paraphrase my colleague
John Bishop's evocative words
in a lead line vault somewhere
out in Culpeper, Virginia.
And 40 years later they're able
to see the fruits of their work
through the digitization project
that Ann Hoog has been
championing here
at the library of the field surveys.
Likewise, the materials
which have been,
the Fuchs recordings have
a much older genealogy.
But again, in the 21st century we're
now able to hear some of the fruits
of that digitization work and bring
1890s recordings up to date in 2016.
Which I think is pretty
fabulous, I mean 126 years
after the fact is a pretty
interesting stretch of time.
So, this project's envision
is a proof of concept.
It's already bearing fruit and I'm
going to just cut myself off there
and turn it over to Kim who is
going to start the proceedings.
And we're going to go through with
Kim, Jane, James, and then Donald.
Take it away, Kim.
>> Kim Christen: Okay,
thank you, Guha.
I am on. Thank you and Niki
and Betsy wherever you
are for the invitations.
And a big congratulations to Judith.
It's a well-deserved award
and I know you were one
of the first people I met here
at the Library of Congress
and you've been, I know you've
just been working tirelessly
on this stuff so, congratulations,
well deserved.
So, I am going to talk
about Mukurtu CMS,
which is a content
management system,
in just a moment, as Guha said.
But I sort of also
want to frame this.
Ad we'll get talking about the
larger project, and my piece in it
in talking about Mukurtu, but I want
to sort of frame that in thinking
about sort of practices
of representation.
Where Mukurtu comes from.
We didn't, just sort of it
didn't come out of thin air.
So, how is it that these histories
of colonialism, and display,
and archiving been interrupted by
indigenous peoples in many ways.
And so, I want to talk
about that first.
As you can see here, in Australia,
aboriginal practices of masking,
deleting or defaming images, objects
and artifacts are quite common.
This was, I first saw in Australia
in, I believe this was in 1995
at Leroux, because an
elder had passed away.
The community members had gone in
with duct tape, as you can see here,
much to the dismay of some of
the non-aboriginal curators.
So, you can see this sort of very
physical masking in public places.
And this has been taken
into the digital realm.
We can see that, now you know it's
very common at least in Australia
to have these sorts of
warnings that you'll see
on websites, on books, on TVs.
This one says, this may cause
sadness and distress to aboriginal
and Torres Strait Islander people.
So, it's warning you
before, if you want to go.
Do you not want to see these images.
In Canada, the Musqueam
Indian Band's online place,
name and archive exhibit
requires visitors
to accept their terms for viewing.
And I love this because it's
a twist on terms of service.
This is their terms for
viewing Musqueam places
and hearing Musqueam
stories in the Halkomelem?
language. So, you actually have to
accept, and only upon accepting,
which includes being respectful and
then not reproducing any portion
of the site without permission.
But it starts that you're actually,
you know you're obliged to act
in a certain way by
accepting these terms.
And so, I think whoever came up with
that in the Musqueam Indian Band
also deserves an award I think.
Once you do click in, you
can still only see some
of the content, videos and maps.
And you will hear them in
the Halkomelem language.
And sometimes not translated into
English, which is another thing
that you'll find on sites.
It's that very disruption of what
most internet viewers are expecting,
is oh, I'm going to
hear it in this language
and then I'll be able
to understand it.
Well, no you won't.
Or you can go and talk to
somebody and learn about it.
At the Northwestern Museum of
Art and Culture in Spokane,
where I work there is, I don't
work at the Northwestern Museum Art
and Culture, but in Spokane,
there's a room where access
to some materials are
restricted to the general public.
So, you can see sacred
room restricted access.
So, all of these, these are just a
small sampling of what's out there
when you start to look for
these sort of interruptions
to our viewing practices.
They're sort of, they're
visual reminders of that sort
of really tactile material
and embodied ethical practice
about not seeing, and not retelling
or retelling in a different way.
And all of those, I think call
into question our assumptions
about knowledge acquisition.
How we learn.
We should be able to see to learn.
Especially in archives,
museums and libraries.
These are very visual
and oral places.
And we're expecting
those things to be open.
So, what these actually help
us think differently though
about the circulation and access
of content in archival collections
and when they are digitized.
So, Mukurtu CMS fits into
this landscape of interruption
and different modes of access and
circulation by providing a tool
that allows communities, however
those communities are defined,
to use their own protocols
for viewing, sharing
and managing digital materials.
Mukurtu is the Warumungu
word for dillybag.
And the dillybag traditionally
held sacred items.
And the elders had to
open up the dillybag
for the younger generations.
But the younger generations also
had to ask and elicit those.
And so, it's about a conversation.
It wasn't about opening
up or keeping closed,
it was about that conversation.
A dialogue and sharing
cultural knowledge
between generations about respect.
And so, it was by the
Warumungu elder that I worked
with Michael Jampin Jones, said the
dillybag is a safekeeping place.
And he also wanted Mukurtu, the
system we created in 2009 to be
that same sort of safekeeping
place that invites dialogue.
That invites conversation.
That's about sharing, but
sharing in a proper way.
And so, flash forward 8 years
later, Mukurtu is now at a 2.0.5
as of three weeks ago release.
Only those of you in the throes
of software releases know
that that really matters in any
kind of way, but yeah us [laughter].
And is see out in the audience,
too, a shout out to the multiple NEH
and possibly IMLS maybe program
officers who have been with us
from the beginning, Joel
Ruhl [assumed spelling]
and others, thank you very much.
We were funded initially by an NEH
startup grant, and have been funded
by IMLS over the last few years.
And also, Library of Congress and
AFC and Guha were one of the first
to jump onto this notion,
well how do we do this?
How do we think about this
in this other context?
So, Mukurtu is now a free
and open source piece
of software that's now
totally configurable.
So, it started out for one community
in the outback of Australia,
800 people serving a very specific
need, with very specific protocols.
So, how do we take that and scale
that up so anyone can use that,
any community can use that in
conversation and in dialogue
with other institutions with
national repositories, etcetera.
Because what we found, and what
indigenous communities already knew
is that a lot of those
collections are out.
They're in other places.
That's the history of colonialism
that we're talking about.
The history of collection
is the history
of colonialism, right full-stop.
So, how do we start there?
Yes, how do we start there?
So, how do we return these and
return these in respectful ways.
So, the basis of Mukurtu
then is what we sort
of lovingly call the three C's.
So, within Mukurtu,
there are communities.
So, you can define those communities
any way, then we'll hear from James
and Donald and their work
about thinking of this
in their own communities.
Communities can be
2 people, 50 people,
500, 5000; it doesn't matter.
They're defined however
you want to within Mukurtu,
nothing comes predefined.
The second thing is
these cultural protocols.
So, the communities
are the who of Mukurtu,
the cultural protocols are the how.
And this is where it happens.
How do you want those
material accessed?
So, we've seen lots of different
cultural protocols over the years
from communities, gender, kin,
clans, medicine societies.
And now that we're working with
more tribal museums and archives,
we're also seeing things
like to be vetted,
or tribal council,
or you know curators.
And then those can be layered.
And so, you could have one
particular image, or a song,
or a video that might only be
able to be heard or seen by women
from a certain clan at
a certain time of year.
So, it can get to that
really granular level
of access between open and closed.
And this happens for every
piece of content within Mukurtu.
Everything has to have a
community and a protocol.
There is no default.
And then, finally categories.
The categories are
the what of Mukurtu.
And so, we don't have
any predefined system
within Mukurtu for categorization.
So, librarians and
archivists close your ears,
I know that hurts your
head to think about,
there are no controlled
vocabularies in there.
You, communities can,
if they want use Library
of Congress subject headings,
but we found very early
on that those don't work.
That a one bucket for Indians of
the Pacific Northwest does not work
for the range of communities.
So, how? It's very important also to
turn that history again on its head.
And so, within Mukurtu, you
can customize these in any way.
So, let me give you an example.
This comes from the
Plateau People's Web Portal
that Guha mentioned earlier.
We're in our eighth year now of
the Plateau People's Web Portal.
We work with the Northwest
Museum of Art and Culture.
And this is in the Warm
Springs community in Oregon.
And they choose this
bag to be digitized.
So, you can see we have the
Northwest Museum of Art and Culture.
This is their metadata that came.
This is all anybody knew about this
basket at the museum, obviously.
And it's very sort of
standard museum metadata.
And the text says, "a round
twine cylindrical cornhusk bag."
That's great.
I'm okay with that.
You know, if that's
as much as we have.
However, after consultation
with the Warm Springs community,
they added their own record.
So, visually, you see I just
moved from one tab to the other.
It's not hierarchical,
it's not a comment.
It's another record.
And in this record, now, the Warm
Springs record, we have their title.
It's not a root basket, it's
actually the duck basket.
We have their protocol.
This actually says Warm
Springs Public Access.
So, public is not a default.
The protocol has to
be added to the item.
And that's very purposeful
on our part.
Because public is one
way of sharing only.
And the Warm Springs actually
have about eight protocols,
but I'm only showing you the
public access ones obviously.
And then they have their TK
label, which Jane will talk
about later, so I'm not going to.
But then you can see here,
there's a cultural narrative,
and an oral history that
was given by three members
of the Warm Springs community.
And in addition to that we
have a video that they created.
>> Speaker 1: Yeah, to me this
looks like a legend on this bag.
After you got it and
see that this is there,
[foreign word] for legendary.
Then [foreign word] the ducks.
Back in those days, you know,
the people themselves argued
over how the duck made its sound.
And they says, no it goes like this
[clucking]; the other one says,
child, no it goes like
this [growling].
And, a coyote was listening to
them, pretty soon they separated
and the people divided
up because the ones
that agreed this is the way
the duck makes its sound
and others said no its this way.
So, they divided up and left,
went and lived somewhere else.
>> Speaker 2: My grandpa
used to say that one
of these days I know I'm going
to go north and I'm going
to hear Wasco people talking
and it will be our long-lost
relatives [laughter].
>> Speaker 1: See,
there they are talking.
>> Speaker 2: Yeah.
>> Speaker 1: They're
talking [laughter].
>> Speaker 2: You'll need
to take a picture of that
and tell a story like
that [laughter].
>> Kim Christen: So, this ends up
being really expanding the record.
You get so much more
than that root twine bag.
And that's really what
this is about.
And I know Guha, I'm going to stop.
I just wanted to say, that this
is really about the relationships.
This happened over eight years.
Again, thank you to NEH
for continued unfunded
extensions of our grant.
But because it is really about
building these relationships.
You don't walk in and
sit down with elders,
and they're going to
tell you a story.
This was over eight years.
And so, the work of this, although
the digital seems really fast,
it's not really fast.
And that's okay.
It's slow.
If we have ten of these,
we have, well I'm not even
when people ask me about;
anyways, I'm going to stop now.
So, I know, I know, I
know, I know, I know.
Sorry, sorry.
Okay. So.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you, Kim.
I think it calls into question one
of the tenants of archival practice
which has been a fashion lately
about the more product
less process methodology.
And I, for one, have never been
comfortable with that notion.
I think what Kim and folks
up here; Jane, and James,
and Donald will tell you about is
that the process is everything.
No matter how long it takes.
And that certainly holds
true as Judith as pointed
out for the extensive
consultation which the library did
over the course of its time with the
Federal Cylinder Project and beyond,
thanks to the vision, and
the work of Alan Jabbour
and other people here
at the library.
That ends my two-minute sermonizing
for the library and
on to Jane Anderson.
Jane, take it away.
>> Jane Anderson: Okay,
thank you, Guha.
Again, thank you so much for
the invitation to be here.
To Betsy and to Niki and
congratulations to Judith.
It's an amazing honor.
It's a privilege to be here.
What I'm going to talk about is one
little piece of this larger complex
that really illustrates
just how much collections
of indigenous material
are different.
And they're different, and they
need a different kind of politics
of care, and politics
of engagement as well.
So, if we think about the
conditions under which a lot
of this material was collected,
we also have to acknowledge,
as Kim mentioned from the beginning,
that those conditions
were uneven and unequal.
The research practices
that were in place
at that time did not
allow indigenous names
to be necessarily included
in catalog entries.
But, the part that I'm going to
focus on, which is where I come
into it is around the
intellectual property rights,
around the copyright.
The way in which copyright has
historically actually functioned
as a tool of exclusion that is meant
that indigenous people
are not the owners
of this material to start with.
And therefore, now in the present
have very difficult challenges
in terms of setting conditions
for access and for circulation.
So, one of the kind of
encounters that we have
with intellectual property law is
that because researchers were the
ones with the equipment and the ones
who did a lot of the
documentation, they became kind
of accidental owners
is how I term this.
They didn't necessarily know that
they were going to become the owners
of this material, the
legal rights holders just
because they pressed play
on the sound recordings,
or that they took the photographs.
That's an accidental kind
of copyright ownership.
And copyright is largely just
interested in what the content is.
It's kind of just how that
body of law functions.
And what adds to that
complication in the present is
that copyright law has very
distinct forms of protection
for different kinds of materials.
So, for instance, photographs are
protected for some period of time.
Sound recording are protected
for another period of time.
Manuscripts are protected
So, if you're from an indigenous
community coming to deal
with one person's collection,
which is largely made
up of sound recordings, photographs
and manuscripts, you're dealing
with quite complicated areas
of copyright law that you have
to then navigate and negotiate.
So, for example, in the United
States, just as kind of one example,
and that really matters for kind
of the issue of sound recordings
that we've been discussing.
Sound recordings are
largely protected until 2067.
So, even the earliest sound
recordings, that we're going
to be talking about
today, from 1893,
are still under protection
until 2067.
That is an inordinately long period
of time to having to be thinking
about what that protection
means, to be getting permission
and to be negotiating that kind of
term of copyright protection period.
So, the intervention that we came up
with and it was largely in response
to this problem of who owns the
materials and what does that mean
for control, and for access and
circulation, was to think initially
about coming up with a set
of very specific licenses
for indigenous material.
And this just kind of came
out of the Mukurtu project.
It was an issue that
came up for communities
that were having their material
returned back into Mukurtu.
But we kind of struck a
rather significant problem
in that first iteration
of developing this project
around the traditional licenses.
And that was that indigenous
communities largely don't own
that material.
And if you don't own that material,
you can't create a
license around it.
And so instead of kind of putting
our efforts into developing licenses
that would only serve,
perhaps 10% of material
that we were dealing with.
We kind of took a detour and came
up with another intervention,
which is a social and
educational intervention.
It's not a legal intervention.
But it is to deal with the
problem that nearly 90%
of the material we're
dealing with is not owned
by indigenous communities and
yet there is still a need to deal
with those problems of authorship,
and ownership and circulation
in a way that kind of counters these
historical legacies of exclusion.
And so, we came up with
the Traditional Knowledge
Labels Project.
So, local context is the
platform that we established,
which is kind of, it's
got two purposes.
The first is kind of an educational
framework, education in terms
of providing information
about intellectual property
law, about copyright.
Giving kind of people capacity to
make informed decisions about when
to use copyright, or when
not to use copyright.
What do the terms of copyright mean.
There's a whole educational
resources section,
that we are slowly,
slowly developing.
And I should also say this project
has just received an amazing grant
from the NEH, so we're
incredibly grateful for that
in order to keep it moving along.
And so, the first part
of the local context is
to provide these educational
resources, to provide tutorials
to help people understand.
Because copyright is a
complicated area of law.
It's a complicated area
of law for everybody,
not just indigenous communities.
So, we were trying to really find
that way to provide those resources
that can be really used usefully.
But the second part
of the intervention are these
traditional knowledge labels.
And they're probably the most
exciting part of this project.
At the moment, we have 13
labels that we've developed,
though James we recently were
working with James with Penobscot
and there's another two labels
that we're going to develop out of
that work, which James is going to
talk a little bit about, presently.
But what's interesting about the
labels is because they're not legal,
we're allowed a little flexibility
in what we can kind of label.
And they really, we might want
to see the labels as
external protocols.
So, we have labels for attribution.
Attribution allow names to
come back into the record.
So, so much of these collections,
they have not got indigenous
names with them.
Either the name of the community,
or the name of the individuals
who were actually recorded.
You might find that
way down in the notes.
But it's not at the top when
you actually are searching
for that material.
We have a label for
different kinds of uses.
So, so much about these labels is
less that they're used internally,
though they are used internally
to help communities
navigate this material
within a system like Mukurtu.
And you saw the TK
attribution label.
They're really for external users
who encounter indigenous
material in all kinds of context.
We have an outreach label
that is largely about sharing,
conditions of sharing, what
do those conditions look like?
When we initially imagined this
project, we had a sense that we,
what we would create on
local context was kind
of a template, a guide.
What could you use this label for.
I mean, also at a theoretical
level we were struck with a dilemma
of how do you standardize something
at the same time as allowing
for the unique expression
of community, ideals,
and decision making
within that label itself.
And I'm going to show
you and example
of how that's kind of working.
But this is kind of the
framework that we developed.
It allows you to kind of see
why would you use this label,
and the TK label description.
And for this one, for attribution,
and again, it's important
that it's not authorship, it's
important that it's not ownership.
And we're really seeking to kind
of like again, twist these ideas
of what attribution and
authorship and authority
over cultural material is.
And this labeled description
reads, this label, I can't see it.
So, this label is being used
to correct historical mistakes
or exclusions pertaining
to this material.
This is especially in relationship
to the names of the people involved
in performing or making this
work and/or correctly naming the
community from which
it originally derives.
As a user, you are being asked to
also apply the correct attribution
in any future use of this work.
So, you can see that it's kind
of a very specific intervention
into the practices of citation, into
the practices of excluding names
in the way in which this material
is circulated into the future.
So, this is a community
that we've been working
with for several years
now in British Columbia.
This is the language.
This material is we've been
working with for several years now.
This is a Scowlitz band of
the Sto:lo First Nation.
And they created a website that
they wanted to tell their story
of the history of archeology.
And you can see at the top,
as part of their website,
they decided they wanted to
use, they chose full labels
from the suite of 13 that we have,
that help people navigate the site
and understand what Scowlitz
perspectives of user engagement
with their content could be.
Again, it's asking people
to slow down and to kind
of take a different way of
understanding how you engage
with digital content
in this kind of way
in which we consume it so quickly.
So, what we do with the TK
labels is we create workshops
that allow communities to define
these labels in their own terms.
And this is the definition
that the Scowlitz came up with
for attribution, [foreign word].
And you can see this is the; they've
decided to use their language,
Halkomelem, as the rerouting
point to start thinking out of.
And this is kind of what they wrote.
This website represents
the true knowledge
and history of Scowlitz people.
The attribution label, which really
means naming place in our language.
We ask everyone that visits this
website to attribute our knowledge
and histories to us, the Scowlitz
First Nation, the tribe of Sto:lo.
Our history has not always been
respected or told correctly.
Here, we tell our own
story in our own words.
We are both holders and caretakers
of our own land, resources
and histories.
It is the responsibilities of
our families and communities,
as Sto:lo people to take care of
these things in a respectful way.
Please feel free to contact us with
further questions about attribution.
So, in that website which is
going to be launched in October,
I believe, I mean it's had so
much consultation involved in it,
so it's kind of slowly
being assembled,
but it's an amazing website,
where you can really see how
they've actually put these labels
on their content and really
asking people for a different kind
of understanding of how this
material could be used, and accessed
and circulated on the
Scowlitz terms.
And that's kind of
what these labels do.
They reorient the terms
of engagement.
I'm not going to talk to you much
about this, sorry, audio people.
The project that we're
working on with Donald is
around the Jesse Fuchs' material.
Again, you can tell from the
way in which we're talking
that Jesse Fuchs becomes the
primary indicator of the author,
rather than the speakers that,
the Passamaquoddy speakers
that were the people who
actually shared this material,
and shared the songs, and
shared the spoken word.
What we're seeking to do here is
to kind of reroute the record,
in particular ways, add
important material back
into the marked record changes.
This is kind of a markup
of some of the places
where that change will happen.
And then this is a markup of
where those labels will be placed
within the kind of Library
of Congress catalog system.
This is a markup on actually the
Omaha material, but we had to kind
of move through different kind of
spaces to have this negotiated.
But just to give you a sense of what
having that label in there starts
to do and what it starts
to look like.
We also have developing an
adapter that allows communities
to develop their own labels
without us being present,
which is really important.
We don't have time
to discuss that now.
I'll kind of hand over to James.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you, Jane.
This is a very exciting
development, as we all know.
And perhaps during the middle of
the discussion we can get Niki,
and or Maggie or other people
who have been working on it
from the library end to comment
on what it means for the library
to incorporate these
sorts of attributions
into our own catalog record.
It's a significant develop.
And again, paid party
political announcement,
I think it's really significant
that the National Library
of the United States,
is to undertaking this
as a first step among lots
of other different cultural
heritage agencies.
So, yeah for us.
Now, Mr. James Francis.
>> James Francis: Well, apparently,
I don't have a slide
for myself [laughter].
>> Kim Christen: I can add one in
while you're talking [laughter].
>> James Francis: So, just a
little bit about our community
and how we kind of; who lived, give
us some context about why we kind
of move forward the way we do.
We were a very mobile
society, moving seasonally
across the landscape in a very
sophisticated, migratory pattern.
And when fall would come and
into the into the winter months,
we would gather in kinship groups.
So, you were with your family;
matrilineal, and with your family.
And it was during those
winter moons when stories
and oral histories were passed down.
And so, what happens and when
you start looking at the history
of our community from
our community they come
down through familial lines.
They come down through family lines.
And so, when you fast-forward to
today when you have a cultural
and historic preservation department
which I am the director of,
it's not about us like
gathering up all this information
and holding all this information.
Because that's outside
of the cultural norm,
because this information
falls within family lines
and it belongs to those families.
But, how do we, as a
department, foster and help share
that information with
the broader community.
And so, given the Mukurtu really
gave us this really safe platform
to be able to set the
protocols, you know, on our terms.
Whether it's, you know,
familiar lines;
if they want to share
it outside of that.
But one of the things that we did
when we sat down and started looking
at the TK labels was to create
a community voice label.
And what we really are looking
and excited about with Mukurtu is
to take a historic photo collection
that we have, and also photos
of material culture and
really start to elicit
from the community
voice about that stuff.
You know, it isn't up to the Culture
and Historic Preservation Department
to be the be-all end-all of all
information about Penobscot.
We want a community voice.
We want to hear from you know, my
grandmother, or their grandmother,
or just people living in
California who are tribal members.
And this digital platform
allows us to do that.
And to share, safely, a story that
is very intimate to your family.
And only share it with
either your family,
or with the broader
Penobscot community.
And so, what happens over time is
these stories start to snowball.
And we start to, we start to have
our history unfolding before us.
And so, it's a really
exciting time for us.
Because you know, we're
starting to hear these stories
that haven't been told
for a long time.
You know, oftentimes, we
got criticized by, you know,
ethnographers that there's
three different versions
of that same story,
which one's right.
Well, there's three different
versions, because they probably came
through three different families.
And none of them are wrong.
They're all correct.
They all hold that
core belief system.
You know the beautiful thing about
oral history is that it's told
by an elder to a younger.
And then, that younger holds
that story for his whole life,
before he becomes an
elder and retells that.
But when he does retell that,
that story has his life
experience woven into it.
He uses examples that are
relevant to his contemporaries.
He uses language that are
So, as oral histories are passed
down through time, they evolve
and change with the people.
That core belief is always there.
You know, people ask, you know,
do you still have oral
stories in your community?
And I always say absolutely.
They may not look like you know
[inaudible] and the moose stories,
but that same understanding about
what you need to hunt to get food
for your family are
passed down within,
from the lines within our community.
And that's the core belief
of what oral stories do.
And what's great about
Mukurtu and the TK labels is
that this has given us a digital
presence, a safe digital presence.
And I stress the safe
because you know,
in our communities we're
often guarded about,
you know, archives and sharing.
Because so much take, take, take,
take, take, take, take, take, take,
take, take has been happening in
our communities and it's time for us
to protect ourselves and protect
our stories, you know, on our terms.
And Mukurtu and the
TK labels are exactly
that tool that's going
to allow us to do that.
And while meeting our community
members where they're at
and where we're all at
these days are in front
of a screen looking
at digital material.
So, that's all I have to say.
I just wanted to thank
these lovely ladies
for bringing this technology
to the communities.
It's changing our community
for the better.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you, James.
Parenthetically, I'll note
that both Donald and James,
and other native committee members
will be here this week visiting the
archives at the American
Folklife Center.
Also, our colleagues
in the manuscript division
here at the library.
But also going out to our
friends and colleagues
at the National Anthropological
Archives of the Smithsonian
and the Museum of the
American Indian.
So, it's an honor, and a pleasure
and a privilege to host these folks.
And now, we come to Mr.
Donald Soctomah, sir.
>> Donald Soctomah: [Foreign
word] Good morning to everybody.
Thank you.
I'm really honored to be here.
I'm really honored to be
engaged in this activity,
because it's bringing voice
back to our community.
About 100 years ago, our
community was 100% fluent,
today in the language 10% of our
population are fluent speakers
in the Passamaquoddy language.
But the life expectancy in
our tribe is right around 50.
And, so we have a problem with our
fluent speakers are really dying
at a fast rate.
So, that makes our job more
important, because we have to reach
out to the community in
a short amount of time.
We recently had a man
pass on, he was 99.
And he was the leader
of the language revitalization
in our community.
And he eventually, with help,
developed the first Passamaquoddy
dictionary which is online.
It's an audio dictionary.
But he was our link to
these wax cylinders.
Ninety-nine, his godfather was one
of the speakers in
the wax cylinders.
So, we were able to, just
by listening to him talk,
tell us exactly what he was saying.
Because in 100 years, voices change.
A hundred years ago French
was our second language.
So, when somebody speaking
Passamaquoddy they're going
to have a little French accent.
Well, today pretty much English
has taken over everything.
And the accent is a
little bit different.
So, if you don't know
that you sort of get lost
in the wax cylinder recordings.
So, it's a real treasure for these
to come back to the community.
A hundred years ago, not only
our language was declining,
but our ways to go underground.
I was interviewing this elder
one time and she told me,
she said when the lights
went out at the convent,
we'd go to the tribal hall
and start to play the drum,
and would sing the old songs.
And then, they'd do
that about once a week.
It was safety for them to do that.
And it just showed me how strong
our culture is and how, you know,
we have to keep pushing
forward to save the culture.
Because they had to do it
because they'd be punished.
They'd be punished for
singing the old songs.
They'd be punished by not getting
food or being looked down upon.
As I was growing up in the 1960s,
there were still traditional
families in our community
that practiced their own way.
And people from the church
would call them witches.
So, it was a way of looking
down upon those people.
But they continued to push
forward and here we are, you know,
those people are leaders
in our culture,
because they kept that cultural way.
So, it goes with the
wax cylinder recordings.
The wax cylinder recordings,
some of the songs almost
disappeared in our community.
The elders remembered bits
and pieces of the song.
They say, I remember that
when I was little, you know.
And then when we're able
to hear these wax cylinders,
they broke out in song.
And we have an example
here, are two examples.
One of the snake song
from the wax cylinder.
If you haven't heard wax cylinder
recordings that were recorded
in the 1890s, these were the first
field recordings of wax cylinders.
So, yeah, lets.
>> Kim Christen: Do you
want me to play that?
Yeah. I think it needs to go off
of the folk life grand
here for a minute.
Okay.
>> Speaker 3: Make
song and description
by Newel Georgia [assumed spelling]
of the Passamaquoddy tribe
[inaudible], March the 18th 1890.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Donald Soctomah:
So, you know, this is,
today this is played
during our ceremonial days.
The snake song is a
very powerful song.
A lot of the tribes
across the nation
and in Canada do the snake dance.
And the snake is a
very powerful creature.
And I want you to hear.
One of our singers heard
the song for the first time,
and thoughts of her youth, and
thoughts of hearing bits and pieces
of the song came back and
she broke out into a song.
[ Singing in Foreign Language ]
You'll have to excuse my
singing in the background,
I didn't realize I was singing.
I'll remember not to sing that.
But, so what I'm doing with
the wax cylinder recordings,
is I'm taking them to the community,
we're having group
listening sessions.
And some of our younger singers
that can't speak the language,
but they understand music,
they're taking the beat.
The beat is really important.
And then, they're learning
the language to fill that in.
And it's making the complete
circle like I spoke to before
about the circle, how it comes
around it comes back
to the community.
Now, we have our ancestors
from 1890 speaking to us.
You know that's really
powerful, really powerful.
And you wouldn't believe, but
some of the people, you know,
the older people break down and
cry when they hear the songs
of their great-great-grandfather,
or the stories
that they heard bits
and pieces of before.
So, the labels are going to be
powerful on this too because some
of these songs are only
meant for certain ceremonies.
Some are only meant for men.
Some are only meant for women.
And then the stories; some of
the stories, what I'm afraid
of is somebody might hear the
story and write a book about it.
And then they claim
ownership of the story.
You know, that's happened before.
One of our neighboring tribes the
Maliseet, there was a researcher
in their community back in the
thirties and he wrote down stories.
He spent two years in the
community gathering stories.
And he promised the community
that the stories were theirs.
Well, he passed on, his children
ended up having the book published.
And now the Maliseets are told
you don't own these stories.
You know, that's not right.
So, I'm glad I have the opportunity
to come here, to talk about it.
To work with Guha, the
Library of Congress.
And it's really going to
bring back some of the songs,
some of the stories
to our community.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you, Donald.
Thanks to all the panel.
I just wanted to make note that
that particular session was filmed
at a community consultation
visit that Jane
and Kim very kindly invited me
along to in March, was it March?
Something like that, which was
actually quite I don't know March
or something like that.
March or April.
So, we were not but
about 100 yards away
from where Jesse Walter
Fuchs recorded Little Joseph
and Peter Selmore [assumed
spelling], the two men you hear
on the recordings of
the Passamaquoddy.
I thought that was a
pretty special moment.
I'm going to open up for questions.
I think I see some nodding
heads and some other people.
Obviously, some of the
people we'd like to hear form
and also again acknowledge the
support of the federal government
for this particular set of
projects between Kim and Jane,
which have a very direct
benefit to the community.
Our colleagues from NEH and IMLS.
So, thanks again for making the
feds look good in this day and age.
But, do we have, we have people
standing by with microphones,
and I'm happy to jump
in with questions.
But, please there's two
questions right to your right.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Speaker 4: I want to
acknowledge our visitors
from Penobscot and Passamaquoddy.
I'm working with Latin
American indigenous communities,
media production.
Mostly analog right now.
And in the TK label project
I noticed there's a button
that says translate.
So, how do we make these
best practices conveyable
to other communities?
>> Jane Anderson: Yeah,
that's a great question Malia,
thanks for coming as well.
So, we're in the process of
actually translating them.
A colleague of yours Maria
Montenegro [assumed spelling],
who you know, who's been involved
in the translation of these labels.
Because we have acknowledged from
the very beginning that there needs
that translation capacity
because there are large amount
of communities who would
like to use these labels.
So, Spanish is our first language
that we're doing translation into.
Given the enormous amounts of
material that are also held
in institutions and
in other context.
So, I mean in many ways this
is a very, very new project.
It's only four years old and
the work that we're trying
to do is you know, is
emergent in many ways,
in the sense that we respond largely
to communities that we get contacted
by and then we kind of build
different kinds of components
that support those communities.
We've just been contacted by, and
why did do that Spanish translation
for a community in
Chile who is thinking
about starting to use the labels.
And so, we're kind of working
closely in relationship with that.
Don't necessarily know what
that's going to look like yet,
but it's kind of the
direction that the labels,
they tend to have their own
life, which is very interesting
in how they get adapted, and
adopted and re-appropriated
within each context
is very different.
And we're kind of like
slowly amassing examples
of what that looks like.
Because they're really
largely in the testing phase.
And we're still in the testing phase
of what this is and
what this can be.
What's very clear for us, is
how they do work for communities
in the sense that they
allow communities
to express their own cultural
protocols in their own terms
and also in their own
languages as needed.
And also, on the flipside
for institutions,
they give institutions a
mechanism to start dealing
with these colonial legacies
that many institutions know
that they have in their collection,
but there is no real
device to get at that.
And so, having these labels
really functions as a means
to bringing institutions
and communities together
in a different kind of
engaged relationship.
But also changing these historical
practices that have been uneven.
They allow communities to be
at the decision-making table
in a different kind of way.
And that's what we're really
trying to change as a practice.
>> Kim Christen: And on a
technical side with the NEH grant
that we have right now,
that we just started,
so it will be another few years,
but we do have a beta version
of the adapter/generator,
which will allow.
Because right now Jane
and I go around
and then we do custom versions
and that model obviously
isn't sustainable
for a whole bunch of reasons.
But, we do also know that
communities always ask us,
well who else is using this
and what have they done.
So, part of the local context
website will have examples
of communities who want to share
the labels that they've created.
Because that's always a powerful
way to get communities started.
But what adapter/generator will
do will be allow communities
to translate and transcribe
and adapt the labels in
any way they see fit.
And so that will, you know,
we have a demo version of it,
and in another year and a half or
so, we'll have the final version.
>> Speaker 5: All right,
can you hear me?
Thank you for the presentation,
it was really interesting to hear
from all of you and such
a range of experiences.
In the examples that I have heard
over the past few years form
the TK labels and Mukurtu,
it's all been examples
from the US and Canada.
And so, my question is
actually similar to yours.
Are there examples of communities
where you're taking this
further south in the hemisphere?
My work here is mostly doing
research on indigenous groups
in Central America and
so I see that need daily.
And just interested
in what's happening.
>> Jane Anderson: Yeah, in one
project that we've been engaged
with recently is with
Oxford University.
And they are working in Bolivia.
It's an ornithology collection and
they're trying to create a database
that tells stories
about birds from kind
of all these different contexts.
And Bolivia is one of the sites
that they've actually been
working in for a very long time.
And they have started to incorporate
the labels into their kind
of digital databases as well.
Just again, giving
this kind of expression
of when should this material
be shared, when is it actually
for particular families, what's at
stake in those sharing processes
and the labels allow that
kind of conversation.
>> Kim Christen: No, there
are a couple examples
from archaeological
collaborations through the Center
for Digital Archaeology who hosts
Mukurtu sites and have done,
they have a couple bilingual sites.
But, as Jane said, so far,
I mean it's about, you know,
communities who have come to us.
So, you know, although Mukurtu is
you know a free and open source,
and people can download it.
So, in some senses we don't
know exactly how many.
In other senses the
biggest communities so far
that we've been working with are
Canada, Australia and New Zealand.
We have quite a few
Maori communities who've
in the last year taken it up
with quite a lot of vigor.
And so, you will see various
translations on those sites.
>> Guha Shankar: Let
me, actually extend
that question toward
James and Donald.
I know it's early days for your
projects with Mukurtu and TK labels.
But does this work in a bilingual
context for you, or do you want it
to work in that particular way?
Either one start.
>> James Francis: Well, we
have just digitized our entire
Penobscot dictionary.
Had the speakers say
each and every word.
And one thing, in our previous
training, with Michael,
who works with Kim, was a kind of
a plug-in from Mukurtu that had
to do with, for a dictionary.
And so, although we
have an online database
with all the words
and those are spoken.
We really want to start to look
at the language differently
in these kind of what we
call cultural clusters.
You know, I had an elder once tell
me to truly understand the culture,
you must understand the language.
And to understand the language you
have to understand the culture.
And it always seemed this kind of
catch 22 paradoxical thing where,
you know, which way do I go.
But, you know I think that as a way
that Dr. Siebert [assumed
spelling] set up the dictionary,
was he alphabetized
everything by Penobscot word,
which was in an alphabet
that he created.
And he failed to.
Kind of decode the words.
So, if there's a word for salmon,
it just says, Atlantic salmon.
You know, so here's the Penobscot
word for Atlantic salmon,
then in English is just
says Atlantic salmon.
And a lot of times for
nouns, that's all you get.
And there's no translation really.
I mean we know it's a salmon.
So, you have to look at the
words that are adjacent to it
in the dictionary and
you find things
like it ricochets off the water.
So, there's this action that's
happening that's related
to how my ancestors saw the salmon.
So, these kind of cultural
clusters are really important
and I've been thinking about how
we can use the platform on Mukurtu
to kind of start that work
of decoding some of that.
Because you know there's
a lot of healing that has
to happen in our community.
We don't have the luxury of having
10% of our population be speakers.
As the Passamaquoddy's do.
We're in you know dire straits
as far as that's concerned.
So, there's a lot of
healing that has to happen
in our community around
language loss.
And so, language is
really kind of held closely
to those language keepers.
And really want to share
it within the community.
And so, Mukurtu is you know, really
seen as a platform that's going
to allow us to share it with only
those who we want to share it with.
>> Jane Anderson:
I think translation is just
a really interesting question
within the project in and of itself.
Particularly, when you saw the
Scowlitz translation of attribution,
which was name and place.
When we were recently working
with you, the translation
of attribution was
this is the correct way
with what Penobscot
is kind of putting
out as what attribution means
from a Penobscot standpoint.
So, that's kind of interesting
translation components that happen
at that interface as well.
Because attribution
doesn't necessarily have a
direct translation.
It's kind of what the community
thinks about when they're thinking
about how do they want
to present this
within a label for an institution.
And it's like, well this is
the right way of doing that,
which is kind of again coming out
of the standpoint of the language,
of the Penobscot language,
not out of the standpoint
of the English language,
so it's interesting.
>> Guha Shankar: Donald
can I ask you to take
that question on as well?
>> Donald Soctomah: We're just at
the starting stages of the concept
of Mukurtu, and it's going to take a
lot of work in our community to get,
to move to the next step.
But we're going to do
anything we can to preserve.
If there's a unique way like
this to preserve the language,
to preserve culture,
we're going to do it.
>> Kim Christen: Actually, the
language was one of the first.
It's always been important
for Mukurtu.
All the features and functions
of Mukurtu came from communities
who wanted them, starting
with the Warumungu community.
And we have a community
development software way
that we scope out things.
So, communities ask us for things.
And a dictionary's been something
that communities have asked
for for the last six years.
And James saw a sneak
peek and I'm happy to say
that the dictionary will
actually be a baked in feature
in 2.06 October 10,
so you heard it here.
It will be October 10.
The reason it takes so long,
is that, I mean part of it,
yes is technical, and
part of it, yes, is money.
I'm not saying that.
But part of it is imagining
what a dictionary means.
Some of these are, it's
a very sort of western
and colonial this listing,
and we've had to think,
how can we make something
flexible enough for Penobscot,
for [inaudible] all these
communities who we're working with,
so we took a lot of input and
we had to make it as flexible
as possible while also making sure
that it upholds the, you know,
sort of cores, the heart
and soul of Mukurtu.
So, every word can
have a protocol on it.
This is important.
And this came out of my first work
in aboriginal communities
in Australia.
That's central.
It's like the words themselves,
they're not open and out there.
And so, there are many things that
couldn't be heard by other people
and so ways to do that and
also to make it this sort
of rounded experience, with
audio, with video, for learning,
for all these different things.
So, it is something.
Language is, you know, is sort
of the foundation of
many of these things.
And it was great, the workshop
we were at, Jane was talking
about with Scowlitz, about
translating the labels.
When they translated the sacred
label and translated these others,
just those conversations around I
think on the local context platform
when communities, you
know, start sharing these,
it will I think be a powerful
you know, just set of examples
of turning that language
around itself.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
Jessie?
>> Jessie: Yeah, good morning.
Thank you so much.
This is a wonderful panel and I
guess on behalf of my NEH colleagues
and other funders, it's
always wonderful to hear
about the work that we supported.
But mostly congratulations
for such powerful impacts.
But, speaking from
a personal capacity.
Kim, you made a powerful
statement I think, that the history
of collecting is a
history of colonialism.
And I think that's something
that in cultural heritage
and in professional practice
at least, we often cover
up with standards and
best practices.
And so, it's very powerful
to see the way
that this work is impacting
communities.
And it's such a powerful way to
illustrate that with seeing examples
from collections in the way that
you've reached source communities.
Picking up on the previous
question, I'm wondering though,
what the uptake is
among institutions here.
It's great to hear that the
library is integrating them,
but I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about that.
And I think particularly because
hearing this sort of example
where we can see the actual impacts
of you know, on communities the way
that we relate to these collections.
And just to pick one
example, you know the Society
of American Archivists has kind
of you know front relationship
with the protocols for
Native American materials.
And there's many more.
So, I'd be interested just
to know how this work is impacting
those professional practices
that I think we often like to
forget about these histories.
>> Kim Christen: There's
a whole bunch of threads
in your question, Jessie, thank you.
And thank you.
And thank you to the NEH.
So, I was going to sort of
go on a rant there at the end
about standards, about
user, you know about impact
and these, because I get asked.
And I'm fine because
I know the impulses.
Well how many, well how many.
And I get that.
I do understand.
But that's only one
way to measure impact.
And you know, I get
emails from people.
How many people are using Mukurtu,
or how many people are using portal,
or what's your data on the portal.
It's like I could go look at
the analytics for the portal,
and I actually just like,
really just didn't answer,
I just blew someone off there,
because I got tired of them asking,
because I don't want to answer
how many pieces of content are
in the portal after eight years.
How many this, because
it doesn't matter.
The relationships matter.
And I have to say that NEH
and IMLS are supportive
of understanding differential types
of impact and community impact.
So, thank you to funders.
But that has changed.
The first two proposals
in 2006/2007and I kept the
reviewer's comments for the portal,
were very, very hostile somewhat,
to the notion of, Joel
can attest to this.
To the notions of everything
not being open.
I mean, you know, that this type of
access, and how can they have this.
I mean it was really,
there was very telling
to whoever the reviewers
were, that we don't know.
But having said, you know all that,
we know that there are
users of Mukurtu worldwide.
So, we know there's in
Australia, and New Zealand,
and Canada, and the United States.
We know the numbers of workshops
that we do every year for those.
And we can see that the biggest
change has been the nonnative
repositories now coming to us.
That's the biggest change in the
last two or three years is that.
You know, and Guha, and Betsy
and Niki have been a charge.
They saw the Plateau People's Web
Portal 2008 and hat's off to them
to think how can we do
something like this,
what can we do something like this.
Now it did take eight years to get
something like the labels in here.
So, it is that slow process.
And we also have to remember
that standards are set
from a certain perspective.
And they're the standards of you
know a certain type of professional,
professionalism that discounts what
we're talking about here in terms
of oral histories that change.
And these aren't, you know,
the metadata doesn't stick
and stay the same because it's
fuzzy, or it's you know dynamic,
or those sorts of things, so.
Does that kind of answer you?
>> Jane Anderson: I'm going to.
>> Kim Christen: Are you going to?
>> Jane Anderson: I'm
going to follow up.
>> Kim Christen: Okay.
>> Jane Anderson: I mean it's
interesting to see where desire
around using this kind of material,
like these devices comes from.
And you know, so what can Penobscot,
Penobscot have collections
in over 30 institutions
in the United States.
And so, slowly with the project
that James has been developing
for the Penobscot collections
project,
that is going to have the
implications that those institutions
that have Penobscot
material are going
to start using the Penobscot labels.
So, that just kind of, that
moves from one direction.
Already, for Penobscot, the
Abbe Museum and the University
of Maine wanting to use the labels.
Because they again, I mean it what's
really interesting is it takes
people within institutions
to recognize the problems
that they have with
their collections.
And that's always going to
be the first starting point.
And so, it's always going to be
those relationships to start with.
Those relationships that
acknowledge that the histories
of these collections is problematic
and has all of these kind
of components that have legacies
that deeply carry themselves
into the present, and into
any kind of sharing futures
that you might want to have.
If you have an ethical commitment to
understanding that communities need
to be engaged in that process
form the very beginning.
You know, then we have
institutions like the Field Museum,
which you know, they have very,
very complicated collections.
And they kind of come to us and
say, well who could we partner
with in order to test these
labels in our institution?
And I'd have to say, in every
instance that we're working
with an institution, it's testing
to what extent this is possible.
Because so much invisible
labor happens
at an institutional level too
in order to build the capacity
for the institution to
take on these questions.
And then to actually
develop different practices
and to implement.
And so that just takes time.
So, the project we've
been working on,
this is like in its already
third year, nearly fourth year
around the Ancestral Voices Project.
So, you know that's just kind
of like getting to this stage.
So, there's still so
much to be done.
But it's a kind of slow burn,
but then sometimes it kind
of picks up and goes really fast.
>> Guha Shankar: I guess frankly, I
would say, I mean just as you want
to question the notion
of you know more product,
less process in this
particular instance,
we also want to question
the notion of scaling.
And when I hear the word
scaling, it's always scaling up.
Why not just scale?
You know, why not just
human scale at the level
where people can actually
interact with the material.
So, there are 31 cylinders,
or recordings that the
Passamaquoddy have.
There's a dictionary
of Father [inaudible]
in the National Anthropological
Archive, that's yet another piece
of this puzzle of what language
revitalization language reclamation
might take.
American Philosophical
Society has certain materials.
So, all of these have to be
approached, not by us at the Library
of Congress, and not by
somebody out there; Jane,
or you know Kim can't
necessarily make those kinds of,
they can make some interventions,
but at the end of the day,
it's up to people like Donald
and James to make those decisions
which are going to affect
them on a daily basis.
So, I think the question
that people might have
about how many, is
really out of place.
It's not up to us to
determine how many.
I mean it's up to the Passamaquoddy
to say we have just enough
for our own needs, or
for our own purposes.
So, that's something we might also
wish to consider at a certain level.
As a matter of fact, I think
we're excited because in ways
that we would not be able to
do, Mukurtu, and Passamaquoddy
and Penobscot are actually doing
the aggregation work of all
of these different institutions
and bringing collections together
in ways that we never could.
We know they're out there, but
we're not going to be able to build
that platform or that portal
to do that intellectual work
of gathering those
things in one place.
That really is I think a fundamental
shift, I mean it's 180 degrees away
from the way in which we
think about curating it.
Because that's the point about all
of this is the community
co-curation is at the heart
of this very venture,
and it goes back to what,
you know Carl was saying and
Alan was saying about the way
in which American Folklife Center
approached the Federal Cylinder
Project in the 1980s.
It came at that moment of sharing
and a co-responsibility among
and between communities
and the federal agencies.
So, yeah. Sorry, and a question.
Yes, Chris.
>> Chris: Hi, my name is Chris
from the Brooklyn Arts Council
and I just wanted to address how
Mukurtu has impacted the work we've
been doing in New York State.
I've been working on a project
for the past three years
to address how folklorists
throughout New York State,
and there's about 30 of us,
organizations that receive funding
from the New York State Council
on the Arts folk arts program,
how we share our information
and we are building a
portal built on Mukurtu.
That does so much for us.
It not only allows us to
place our materials online,
which we have a lot of pressure
to do in the public sector.
But it brings the communities
into the process,
which has just been so incredible.
In addition, what I found is that
the idea of sharing in a proper way,
we've been contacted by very,
very small organizations.
One in particular in
Osceola, New York.
They have an old-time fiddler's
Hall of Fame and they heard
about the way we're doing this.
And they don't even have
internet, and there they are.
But they have a wonderful
collection.
But they're excited about the fact
that Mukurtu provides a platform
to share in a proper way to
allow those cultural protocols.
So, I just wanted to say
thanks, but also give an example
of how we're implementing,
or Mukurtu is being used
in a different sort of environment,
and allowing public
sector folklorists
to bring communities back in
to the collections that many
of us have large collections,
so thanks.
>> Kim Christen: Yeah, and I
was contacted by an archivist
who is working with a transgender,
this is the great thing.
I've been doing this for nine years.
And you know it started off, you
know it was a very personal project
with the community in Australia
that I was working with
and it's grown into this thing.
And now, we're starting to see it
move beyond indigenous communities,
just you know it's
transgender archives.
So, there's things in here
that would be, you know,
potentially put people at risk.
So, we want to use
Mukurtu as the platform
to share these oral histories
around this transgender archive.
It's because it's that same set of,
it's going to be safe
for them to do that.
So, I think there's you know these
other multiple instances of its use.
So, it's great to hear
your use, Chris, thank you.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you for
that, because that just reminds me
of what Andrea Kitta and
folks in various roles
and others were saying yesterday
about the notion of access
and discoverability of
individuals whose you know work is,
and it places them at
certain kinds of risk.
And this is yet another
interesting residence,
which I thank my colleagues
for having brought all
these folks together.
Because I'm just really interested
in the crosstalk that's
been happening here.
Yes, please.
Cliff.
>> Cliff: Hi, I'm curious,
James and Donald,
if you had to get tribal government
buy-in into doing this kind of work
and collaborating with
these folks over here.
And if so, how did you kind of
successfully make that case.
How did you kind of bring people in,
you know within your
communities into this cause.
You know, I'm sure you must have
proper channels that you have to go
through for this sort of thing.
>> James Francis: Yeah,
a couple of things.
First of all, we have a
rights protection board
that was formed in
the last five years.
It was a re-formation of some
older research review boards
that really try to
protect Penobscot culture.
So, the tribal council had approved
the formation of this board,
which has some subcommittees
under that and one
of them is intellectual
property rights committee.
That kind of looks at, you
know what is Penobscot,
what do we feel is
important to protect.
And so, it was that committee who
really made the decision to work
with Jane on this grant to
move forward with the Mukurtu.
So, you know, there are
some kind of channels of,
you know it's just not me saying,
you know let's move forward.
You know, it's a group
of people who feel work
like this is important
in the community.
And again, you know, we're using the
platform not for us to have a voice,
but for the community
to have a voice.
So, you know, it's; and that's
ultimately the most important piece
for us.
>> Donald Soctomah:
For us what we did
when we formed our historic
preservation office,
the tribe sort of, our
mission was to do this.
And the tribe is busy with
business, with community issues
for the preservation issues,
that's our assignment.
So, I usually consult with
elders in our community.
And I have a small group of elders
that point the direction to go.
And anything that has to be signed,
like any type of agreement
goes back to council.
But I have to develop and
work with organizations
to develop any type of agreement.
>> Guha Shankar: And I think
that's also another way of talking
about scale in these
particular kinds of projects.
We're, the anti-DPLA,
that's the case.
You know, we're not working
at this like mass scale,
we're working at individual.
>> Kim Christen: We're not
anti, we're not against.
>> Guha Shankar: Anti, the non-DPLA.
Sorry, semantics will
trip us up every time.
>> Kim Christen: They're
recording this.
>> Guha Shankar: Yeah,
of course they are.
Hi. Hello, DPLA.
The point being that again,
each of these is a case,
I mean it's a case
by case basis, right?
It's not mass digitization just
for the sake of mass digitization.
Were it the case that
would be great.
But every individual community
has cultural protocols,
which are internally vetted
and then passed out to us.
Right? It's not something, again,
as very carefully the way that Jane,
and Kim, and Donald, and
James have talked about this,
it's all the negotiated moment.
And we're privileged and proud
to be part of that negotiation.
>> Kim Christen: And I would say
from our end we get, you know,
coming through out support
desk on our site every day,
90% comes from cultural preservation
offices, archivists, librarians.
It's not their IT department making
the decision what content management
system they should use, because
yes, it is a content system,
but, you know, but it's not.
It's not like making a
choice to use content DM
that the IT people
get together and make.
And so, we get down the line, we
get their ID departments involved.
But it's rare.
It has happened.
But it's rare that we get contacted
by you know, an IT department
or something with those more sort
of standards based questions.
And it's really word of mouth.
And that's, you know
and it has really sort
of taken off in the last few years.
But that really is
how it's been for us.
>> Guha Shankar: Any
other hands out there?
Yes, Mary?
>> Mary: Hi there.
I guess this question is for Jane,
but others can comment on it.
What are the training needs
for people in institutions
for this kind of work to take place?
>> Jane Anderson: It's a
very good question, Mary.
I mean the kind of the
first training needs are
around recognizing those
histories of collections.
So, it's an educational training
need on just kind of one level.
And then, I mean I think the
Library of Congress kind of proof
of concept has been a really
good example for thinking
about what the different kinds
of training needs are in terms
of thinking about implementation.
What does it take to
work with the community?
What kind of time period
needs to exist?
Also, what are the questions
of copyright that arise
in each kind of collection.
Understanding what those questions
are about are also a training need.
Partly, because it's
not necessarily clear
or people haven't necessarily
been thinking
about what those copy
right questions are
that either allow the circulation
of material, or actually close
down the circulation of material.
So, that's kind of
at least one point.
There's also training needs
around recognizing how
to work with communities.
And that's a time-based project
and a relationship based project.
And its things don't
happen instantly.
So, there's kind of a sense of
what kind of temporal limits
of a project need to
also be in place.
Training, in terms of implementing
the labels, it's not that difficult
at all, but there has
to be the conversations
between different sections of
the institutions so that they're
in conversation with each other in
order to make that happen as well.
And actually, maybe Niki, you could
actually state a little bit to that,
I think that would be great.
If you wouldn't mind.
>> Kim Christen: Yeah, that
actual technical implementation.
>> Niki: Hi.
Speak to which element
in particular?
Because there are several.
>> Kim Christen: I think
the technical; well,
the sort of meta technical
implementation,
all those meetings we had,
like where it would go
in your content management system,
because it's indigenous to Mukurtu.
If you get Mukurtu
you get the TK labels.
It's like a two for one.
But if you have a different
content management system.
>> Niki: Right, so there were,
yeah, there was lots of discussion
about how big will the label be,
where will it display and all
of those are still open questions.
So, nothing's been finalized.
But yeah, I mean we have
certain technical limitations
like anybody else with the system
that you know if you put something
in this field, it's going to
display at the bottom, you know,
because that's what we do
with all the other zillions
of records we have in our catalog.
So, yeah, we're talking
about how to work that out.
I think your question about
training is really good.
I think one of the, I want to just
add that one of my initial concerns,
and I was getting it from
others was, well, you know,
how are you going to navigate this
once they're on to the next project
and you're stuck, you know
figuring out how to dispute issues
around takedown or changing labels.
And, you know, you
made the point, Jane,
that we're frontloading this, right?
Like we're doing all this engagement
upfront so that theoretically,
you know, this has
been really worked out.
And so, that was a real
turning point for me with this,
where I got my head, you
know, around it more.
>> Guha Shankar: And
I guess the training,
just in a particular example
from the Library of Congress,
is that those are conversations
that's being had not just
between Niki, and Jane,
and Kim, and the community,
and myself in going out,
you know, on site visits.
But also, Maggie Kruesi, who is
on the cataloging staff here,
but also our project
1 team, which is our,
which provides the access point for
all of our public facing portals.
So, that's a lot of moving, and
also general council who's talking
precisely about rights issues.
And so, the training, then is not;
I'm not sure training is
perhaps the right word for it.
But you better be trained to be
having a lot of conversations among
and between your people at
the institutional level.
So, that's something which,
it doesn't force you to talk
to each other, but it
just makes conversation
and the project outcome a lot
smoother if you have people
who are talking to each other
and not in these legendary silos
which we always hear
about within institutions.
And sorry, Niki?
>> Niki: Well, I mean to the
library's credit we took this
to the powers that
be, who govern the web
and they were very receptive.
I mean there was lots of talk
about we want to keep it a pilot,
and we want to you know, put
certain boundaries around it.
But they were hip to the need.
And they knew we needed
to do something.
And so, kudos to us in that regard.
>> Kim Christen: But I think
to Mary's one of the things
for Mary's question is on the local
context site and with the grant
from NEH one of the things we are
going to do is have those sort
of frequently asked questions.
And we have this on our Mukurtu site
because we have had
enough questions.
What does your IT department
need to know?
What does your tribal
council need to know?
What does your archivist
need to know?
So, we have all of this.
And so, we have, and I think
we'll do the same thing
on the local context site,
now that we're seeing.
And the Library of Congress,
this project is actually a really
good one for us to be doing
to figuring this all out, because
the scale of the federal government.
It's like if we can
navigate this, you know,
hopefully we can navigate
other things, right?
I think we've had meetings
with everybody.
Yeah, so we're aces.
So, I just think.
But because we do.
You know, we are thinking, not
necessarily about scale in terms
of number, but we're thinking
about sustainability in terms
of how do we get the
information out to the people
who need it, if we can't always go.
And we love to do these workshops.
This moment with Gracie when
she started singing the song.
I mean it was like,
that was it we're done.
At the time it was like if nothing
else happens with this project,
honestly, if no label
gets put on, if we don't;
if they never have Mukurtu,
if nothing, like being there
in that moment was so amazing, it's
what it's all about, that you know,
that's what we mean in
terms of sustainability.
So, you know, I don't want to blow
off Jessie's question or think
that it was, you know it is a
factor, but let's think about,
you know, sustainability,
human interaction,
relationships for the long term.
Because if we do, if we are
starting from you know the history
of collection is the
history of colonialism,
then we have a lot to repair.
So, we start with the relationships
and that's why I'm really glad
that Donald, and James, and
that we could all be here.
You know, because it is
all of us working together.
None of these parts work separately.
>> Guha Shankar: Our able timekeeper
has given us the time sign.
But I would like to leave it
to our guests form Penobscot
and from Passamaquoddy
to take a moment
to say what their final say might
be, if you have such a thing to say.
Unless you just want
to get to the coffee.
>>
>> James Francis: All I have
to say is [foreign word].
So, we have no word in the
Penobscot language for good-bye,
it means I will see you again.
Thank you.
>> Donald Soctomah: And I just like
to thank again all the powers to be
that gave us the opportunity.
You know, we live in this
remote corner of the country.
And being remote sort
of saved our language.
But now, being remote
is sort of hard to try
to get this material back.
So, I want to thank whoever put this
together, you know, for helping us
because this is going
to bring the energy back
into our community that's really
needed right at this time.
And thanks for the
shot of energy yeah.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: Well,
we've reached the final collection
feature here at the symposium.
So, we want to talk now about one
of our most important projects
and most important collections,
which is the Veterans
History Project.
It's been going on now for
over 10 years and has collected
over 100,000 collections
from American veterans.
Like the American Folklife
Center, it was established
by legislation of the Congress.
And so, it's one of those programs
that that the Congress has decided
is an important priority for us
to be collecting the oral
histories of American veterans.
And so, we're lucky to have with
us a senior reference specialist
from the Veterans History
Project, named Megan Harris.
And I should tell you that there's
this great magazine out there,
we haven't mentioned this yet,
but one of the things on the table
out there is a magazine, "The
Library of Congress Magazine,"
which featured AFC as
its main kind of theme.
So, that's why we selected
this issue.
It's not the most recent issue, but
it's the issue that deals with AFC.
So, please pick this up on
your way out and when you do,
you'll find that Megan
is a celebrity.
Because she's featured as
the "My Job Feature" in a
"Library Congress Magazine."
So, she can tell you about her job,
but also about the Veterans
History Project in general and what
that great project is up to.
So, without further
ado, Megan Harris.
[ Applause ]
>> Megan Harris: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for attending today.
So, my plan for the next
10 to 15 minutes or so is
to give you a little
bit of a brief overview
of the Veterans History Project.
And then, also talk
specifically about the reference
and research end of things.
Because that's my little
sphere of influence
or piece of the pie so-to-speak.
And then, also talk about a
few of our recent acquisitions
that have come in, in
the last year or so.
Some of the most really
intriguing and interesting things
that we've had come
through the door.
It's a little strange not to have
a monitor in front of me here.
So, if I screw up with the slides;
oh, perfect, all right, great.
Thank you.
So, I'm not sure how
familiar folks are
with the Veterans History Project,
but just to give you
a brief overview.
We were created by Congress
in 2000 to collect, preserve,
and make accessible the stories
of America's war veterans.
And in the yeah, in the 15
years since we've been around,
we've collected material relating
to over 100,000 different veterans.
In addition to oral histories, we
also collect other items that help
to tell a veteran's story.
Things like original letters,
diaries, journals, photographs,
memoires, military papers,
two-dimensional pieces of artwork.
Essentially, everything, but
three-dimensional artifacts
that would explain a veteran's
experience and their story.
And we organize material under
each individual veteran's name.
So, when I speak of a
collection, that might refer
to a single oral history, or it
might refer to an oral history,
and five original photographs, or
50 letters, or a 200-page memoir,
or even something like
500 or 1000 letters.
So, our collections really
vary in terms of size,
but all of them relate back to
that individual veteran's story.
So, in terms of how this
material comes to be here,
we essentially asked
the general public
to become Folklife practitioners.
And to go out into their community,
or maybe just out into
their own family
and interview the veteran
in their life.
And the project is
really setup with the idea
that anyone can participate
in the project.
That you don't have to
have any sort of background
in oral history interviewing,
or folklife,
or journalism, or interviewing.
That anyone can take part
and sit down with a veteran
and our field kit, and
go through the process
of either conducting an
interview, or documenting
that veteran's story in another way.
And then submit it here to
the library to be archived.
We provide veterans and interviewers
with a field kit that has a list
of suggested questions,
and all of the paperwork.
All of the release forms that
they would need to participate.
And so, using that field kit,
and then drawing on the expertise
of our staff if they need to.
They simply conduct the
interview, and send it in here
to Veterans History
Project to be archived.
We have collections that
are donated by individuals,
folks who just maybe only went
and interviewed their relative,
or their next-door
neighbor, or their postman.
But we also have collections that
are done on a much wider scope
by different organizations such as
the VFW, and the VA, the Red Cross,
libraries, colleges, and
universities, Boy Scout,
Eagle Scout troops and those
sorts of organizations.
So, individual participation and
then group participation as well.
So, the goal of our
project is really
to document the experience of war.
And we take a very folklife
oriented take on that.
We consider ourselves a social
or cultural history project
and not a straight
military history project.
And our collections really bear this
out, bear out the focus that we have
and the approach that we have.
So, in addition to providing
information and testimony
about more military focused aspects,
things like battles and campaigns,
and unit movements, conflicts.
Our collections also have
a lot to do with things
like military traditions
and folklore.
One of the pictures I included here
was of a crossing the line ceremony,
which is a naval tradition, that
involves costumes and role-playing,
and it's a fantastic
military tradition that a lot
of our naval collections discuss.
I included another picture
here, it's a little hard to see
of a veteran eating some canned
peaches that were in ration.
And food ways are a really
interesting part of our collection.
Looking at how collections; how
veterans in their collections talk
about the experience of food
and eating in the military.
And we also have collections
that include original artwork,
the ways in which veterans
made sense of their experience
and described it in
original artwork.
Drawings, and photographs, and
paintings, and that kind of thing.
So, our collections
have this focus and bear
out this social cultural bend that
we have and really explore things
that you might not expect to find in
military oral history collections.
So, because of our broad
collecting scope, the research use
of our collections
is similarly broad.
We have researchers who
use our collections in some
of the very typical ways
that you might expect.
Things like documentaries
that had to do with say,
the USS Indianapolis, or Pearl
Harbor, or Battle of the Bulge,
D-day, some of those
more traditional scopes.
But then we also have
researchers who use or collections
in very surprising
and unexpected ways.
Folks who have investigated,
using our collections,
the history of martial arts, in the
United States, looking at how boxing
in World War II really
impacted the development
of martial arts after the war.
Or the history of mah-jongg.
Or one recent inquiry had
to do with World War I
and how troops were
entertained during the war.
Both the entertainment that
the military provided to them
and then how they make
their own entertainment.
So, a really wide variety
of different research uses.
And our researchers
come from all over,
and all different walks of life.
Students and teachers,
documentarians,
folks from other agencies such
as the Department of Defense
and the National Park Service,
have all used our collections
in various different ways.
And they've also then used
them in different things
like museum exhibits, print
media, educational resources.
There's currently, on display,
down at the Atlanta Airport actually
is a huge display honoring veterans
that drew about 100
different photographs
of veterans from our collections.
Really interesting use
of VHP collections.
So, if you happen to be travelling
through Atlanta you can check
out the VHP images as
part of that display.
So, lots of varied uses
of our collections.
And ways that they pop up around.
All right.
So, in terms of recent acquisitions,
we get about 100 different
collections a week.
Roughly about 4-500
collections a month.
All of them are interesting, but
there have been a few that have come
through the door that give you a
sense of some of the initiatives
that we've been working on.
But also, things that just pop
through, unexpected acquisitions
that have come through our door.
One initiative that I have been
involved in is with a professor
out in Monterey Bay, California.
She's a professor at California
State University, Monterey Bay,
and she, along with her students
has been documenting the history
of a decommissioned military
base called Fort Ord,
which was a real center for military
personnel up through the 1990s,
when it was decommissioned.
And she has long been documenting
the history of Fort Ord.
So, we partnered with her recently,
not only to interview veterans
of the surrounding
area, but specifically,
one of our processing technicians,
Timmy Kabran [assumed spelling]
and I went out to Monterey
Bay to take part
in something called a stand down,
which was put on by a local
veterans transition center.
And they essentially
brought homeless veterans
from the surrounding
area to Fort Ord
and provided them social
services for a weekend.
We went out there to
help facilitate,
not only interviewing
veterans, homeless veterans
who were being provided services,
but also some of the volunteers
who were supporting the efforts.
And that garnered around 40
different oral histories.
Not only of the homeless veterans,
but also of the volunteers.
And it was a really
wonderful example of something
out of the ordinary that also speaks
to and helps document the stories
of a very underserved, under
documented population demographic
which is homeless veterans.
So, it's a really unique
set of collections
that came out of that initiative.
We had a couple of different
diary collections come
through the door recently.
One came through last December and
it involves a diary that was given
to us by the family of Glenn Piercy,
who might be a familiar name to you.
He has a wonderful civil rights era
photograph collection that's part
of the American Folklife
Center along with his brothers,
Glenn Piercy provided us with
a diary relating to his uncle,
who was a POW in the Pacific
theater during World War II
and unfortunately,
did not make it home.
So, along with this original diary,
he gave us letters and photographs,
you know, just a tremendous
collection relating to his uncle.
He made this collection, we
were kind of blown away by it,
and ended up writing
a blog post about it.
And then about six weeks after
we were contacted by the family
of a friend of his who
he had served with.
Who volunteered that their family
also had an original diary.
So, we now have two of these
very unique, very rare,
original Pacific POW diaries.
They're the only two diaries of
their kind in our collections.
And they're interconnected.
They speak to of another.
Because they come from two
veterans who were buddies.
One of whom made it home
and one of whom did not.
So, that was a really amazing,
both of those acquisitions
were really interesting,
really wonderful acquisitions.
We also have seen a real uptick
in World War I collections
coming through out door.
You might think that with the demise
of the actual World War I generation
of soldiers who served in the
war, that we wouldn't see any more
of those collections, but in fact,
we've seen a definite steady uptick
in our World War I collections
coming through the door.
Mainly things like
correspondence collections,
and photograph collections.
Including one really notable
collection that came from someone
who served with a well-known
unit called the Lost Battalion.
Well-known, infamous for the losses
that they incurred during
one particular battle.
And this, you probably can't
tell at all from the PowerPoint,
but the diary is quite lyrical.
Beautiful prose describing the
veteran's experiences training
and then in combat.
But it's most notable
because it's written
in teeny, teeny, tiny script.
And it's essentially
illegible at this point.
It's almost as if the veteran had
written it using a magnifying glass,
even though I don't
think that was the case.
And it's just tremendous.
And it was also transcribed
in the 1930s.
So, we have a full transcript of it,
in addition to having the original,
which was donated by
the veteran's grandson.
So, that has been one of our most
notable World War I collections.
We've had a lot of researchers
come through recently looking
at our World War I material.
And a lot of it will be incorporated
into the library's World
War I exhibition next year.
So, that's sort of a very brief,
very quick me talking really fast
about the Veterans History Project.
But I'm glad to answer any
questions if we have any time?
No? No, questions.
No time. All right.
Feel free to email me, I'm glad to
answer any questions you might have
about VHP and our collections,
scope, using the collections
for your own research or
anything to do with that.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: So, once
again that was Megan Harris
from the Veterans History Project
and I should mention a couple
of things that she
mentioned in her talk,
including our blog,
"Folklife Today."
So, we haven't talked about that
yet, but it's a great way to find
out what's going on at AFC
and VHP, it's a shared blog
between those two parts
of the library.
So, you know, we have blog posts
about general folklife issues,
but also a lot of blog posts about
the Veterans History Collections,
including great pieces
written by Megan,
she's one of our favorite bloggers.
So, I'm the general editor of that
blog and you can just find it,
the easiest way to find it
actually is on the table outside,
there are bookmarks for
the Folklife Center,
one of which specifically
says Folklife Today on it.
So, look for that one ad you'll
find all the information on there.
So, now we're going to continue
and wrap up the whole symposium.
Because we have with us a great
speaker, and as a great thinker,
a great brain who has been part of
the Folklife Center for a long time.
So, Tom Rankin has been
associated with the Folklife Center
in various ways, including as a
field worker, in our field projects.
But most recently, as a member of
our Board of Trustees and as a chair
of our Board of Trustees
for some years.
Tom has also been the director of
the Center for Documentary Studies
at Duke University, and associated
with that center for a long time.
And also, he's a terrific
documentary photographer himself.
But mainly we love him for his great
brain, that tying up all the issues
that we have in our symposia.
And he's going to come up here
and give us some wonderful
closing remarks.
So, please welcome Tom Rankin.
[ Applause ]
>> Tom Rankin: Well, subtract
the hyperbole there and I could,
you know, I if I was
a 21st century guy
with this crowd sources,
this wrap up.
But, I'm more of a dust to digital
guy, an all deference to Lance.
So, I've been sitting for the
last day and a half taking,
I feel like I'm back
in graduate school.
You know, I couldn't
not pay attention,
because I'm supposed
to wrap up, right?
Which is a good exercise.
And I'm not sure I can do
justice to what's come before,
or to Steve's notion
that I'm a good thinker,
but I'm going to try
to say a few things.
You know, it's so interesting
to be at this moment
at the crossroads of
analog and digital.
Or least I think that way.
You know whatever, however
long this moment is.
I mean we can very easily reach back
and as we've been hearing
we're constantly trying to stay
on the outer edge of what's
possible with this digital moment.
We can still shoot film if we
want, but we digitize everything.
And so, that is and no joke
aside, this sort of dust
to digital to analog, and digital.
Most of us were born analog,
we'll all die digital.
And I think that that's a really
interesting place to get to live.
I often think about
how our, you know,
how are great archival
collections built?
However large or small?
How are they made?
Whose act and whose intent
brought them together.
And I think this notion of intent
that came up a lot, is key.
We find many documentary
collections that had their origins
in just moments of impulse and
chance, and kind of a daring,
Bergis Jules talked in the dark
now, and about Ferguson is you know,
nobody sat down and did an
RIB proposal before they took
to the streets and became
documentarians there.
And it's a good thing they didn't
because they were activists.
They were going on gut.
And yet, we also know that
careful planning, and forecast,
and thinking about what goes on say
in those Archie Green proposals.
Not that those projects don't have
chance and impulse embedded in them.
But there's all this sort
of thinking beforehand
about what's going to happen.
Our great collections are
built by both of those things
and all kinds in between.
The you know, the recording the
making the picture, the interview,
going out and doing things
is the thrilling and easier,
and more inspiring a piece
of this puzzle I think.
But how we do things that last, that
are distinctive, that are important.
That then last and live
responsibly as they last.
How do we take the work that we
want to do and make it relevant,
and then accessible,
and enduring for others.
And again, with this whole notion
that the history of doing so much
of this is the history of
colonialism, or the history
of having the equipment and
therefore you get to tell the story
because you happen to be able
to afford the thing,
the piece of equipment.
The discussions of the last day and
a half have been so clearly to me
about intent, and the deliberate
understanding of goals and intent
that we see when we start talking
about how we should
document the web.
Probably an area that
I know the least about
and was finding myself
most sort of engaged with.
Because it's humbling
to even think about,
what should we preserve
from that whole world.
I was struck in those presentations
by the more the world is virtual.
And I realize these words at least
in the academy are really contested,
virtual and I'll put aside actual.
But the more the world is virtual
and the more we understand the web
to be that virtual world, the
more it may call forth some
of the old verities of
the actual to work in it.
The local, the placed.
When talking about the
Ferguson collection,
we heard that it became most
understood and most useful
to hear the people who made the work
that ended up in the Tweets talk
about making the work that
ended up in the Tweets.
The actual grounded the virtual.
That, if I talk too much about that
I would begin to sound like a kind
of a luddite, but I think
there's some truth there.
Or, when we hear about vaccines, you
know doing work on line about sort
of vaccination feelings in
northeastern, North Carolina.
Without the actual interviews
of people what sense
does any of that make?
How do we get to context without
some of those older approaches.
Let me take my watch off
so I keep track of this.
Just as we have and should probably
forever ponder what right we might
have to go in somebody's
backyard and take a photograph.
You know when Montana Miller
was talking about the web,
she's talking about it as a
similar tender ethical space
that requires us to think of it,
not just as a virtual landscape,
but maybe as something
a little more actual.
Those are complicated things.
But I think the way that
ethics is central to all
of it comes really clear and we may
see it more clearly when we look
at something that we
think of as so virtual.
I think that thinking about working
in those spaces may will
require simply to double
down on the essential
notions of the old.
The survey projects, you know, I'm
so intrigued to hear Allen, and Carl
and others talk about
sort of the origins
of the of the survey projects.
Not that they can; not
that they know themselves
where all the influences came
from, where all the water
of that confluence came for
them to think about photography
and recording, and you know
what influence was the FSA.
And so on, and the
building of these teams.
But to hear that and to
get a sense of that kind
of contextual information.
Also, to see you know, how often
they photographed the doing
and the word reflexive.
You know they were meta
before meta was coo,
to paraphrase a country song.
And why they did it.
Who knows.
Were they doing it so they could
come back here and should people
at the library that they
were actually working?
Were they doing it so that we,
because they were looking forward?
Were they doing it
because they noticed
in the FSA there were a
few pictures like that,
and they were really intriguing?
Who knows?
But I think it allows us to
engage with the process in a way
that just gets us talking
just like I'm talking now.
And to think about it.
And to think about what
it means to be there
and to do those kinds of work.
When Terry Eiler talked about
standing in the same place.
Two photographers standing in
the same place, taking pictures
of the same thing, but
very different pictures,
is an interesting story, but
it's a much larger metaphor
of what it means to think about how
to build documentary collections.
You know, two people
happen to be married,
but who see things very differently.
Two photographs building
teams, getting different points
of view on the same story.
Understanding that of course
there's no one version of any story.
There's no one photograph
of anything.
To really humble us to understand
that these artifacts we create are
impotent even as they are powerful.
The you know we live
in a moment where sort
of gated property has never
been more important to people.
Physical and intellectual.
And the standard and model
of the survey project to be
in the public domain, it will
raise some challenges, probably.
And there'll be some pictures
and recordings, that go out
and people say, man I didn't realize
my grandfather signed that form.
Of course, it's not perfect.
But, if we look at the Farm
Security Administration,
and I tell my students there
are some great photographers
in the FSA club and
great photographs.
But, I always ask them, don't you
think maybe the reason we look
at those pictures so much is
because we can actually use them.
We can actually get to them.
What's the relationship
between quality and access?
Or between accuracy and access?
And I think the survey projects
will take on a life of their own,
which is a little scary probably
for some people even in this room.
But, what better legacy than if 70
years from now people are trying
to download Terry's pictures
and use them for something.
As opposed to the alternative.
So, you know, I think that
we can learn from that.
And I don't know what that means
for our work going
forward and for projects.
But that notion of being
able to get to work.
And yet we've heard stories
where work needs to be
where the documentary
evidence needs to be really,
the access needs to be limited.
This notion that Kevin Bradley said,
you know, I think I got this right,
at the interview he wants
to talk we want to listen.
It's so much at the foundation
of much of what we do.
The Archie Green Projects
in occupational lure,
and this whole notion
of a quiet revolution,
or the whole notion
of recovering voices.
The whole idea of giving
a voice to people
that we don't normally hear from,
or normally pay attention to.
A hairdresser in Lumberton,
North Carolina.
You know, we don't
know anything about,
taking us places we've never been
and may not even, wouldn't think
to go and building
archives around that.
It's so much the bedrock of what
the Folklife Center is about
and what documentary
fieldwork is about.
And I think that Nancy Gross said
something that is a question,
not to answer now, but she said
you know occupational projects
or folklore goes through trends.
People are interested
and not interested.
But I can't think of
anything more important to get
to than why people work, what
they do, how they feel about it.
To really get to where we all live.
I'm really struck by
what we can learn.
You know how is it that we can
learn so much about what we ought
to do now by how people are
handling wax cylinder repatriation,
reciprocation from the 1890,
recordings made in the 1890s.
And what the problems of responsibly
returning that to communities.
But also making it
accessible to all of us.
And ownership, and ethics.
What we can learn from the way
those are being handled now
and software created.
It really can inform how
we do our fieldwork now.
How we do contemporary fieldwork
which is a lot of my own interest,
is you know, what's
going on around us?
What matters?
And what are you going
to do about it?
Which I think is what
documentarians often need
to be thinking and do anyway.
In talking about Ferguson, I
think Bergis said something
like is there a way to communicate,
you know with a collection,
through a collection, is there a
way to communicate how the values;
the values of a collection
and how it should be used.
You know, what are the values,
kind of now how valuable
is the collection,
but what are the embedded
values in that collection.
And I think that's so
key to figuring out,
and sometimes that's
a personal choice,
if it's a personally
created body of work.
And sometimes it's a
vastly communal choice
as I think he was referring to.
One way, and I've got, what?
I've got about 10 minutes
is that right?
I want to talk, close with sort
of what do I worry about,
what do I fret about?
I like to fret more than worry.
But what do I fret about in thinking
about sort of where we are and some
of the things I've heard and
this whole thing we call folklife
and documentary, and
building of collections,
and then creating access
to those collections.
And one of the things I kind
of, and fret is not as bad
as worry, so don't worry.
One of the thing sis just the
sheer abundance and excess
of documentation of today.
That calls for even more skills
of discernment, of intent,
of point of view, of
kind of the vision.
You know, the word
of the decade talked
about by everybody is this
word curation, which both;
I find another way to
sort of build walls.
I mean it sounds so important
that we curate our Facebook page.
But this notion of curation, of
what matters and what doesn't.
And so, while we can sort of
rejoice at the fact that everybody
in this room at this moment could
take a picture of something,
simultaneously, or make a recording,
or you know, is there a way in which
that fact, that mere fact makes us
less discerning, less intentional,
and gives us less of a purpose
in what we were going to.
If it all is recorded,
then why record anything.
And if all is, we're probably
being recorded by something anyway.
And so, so what is it we
want to record and why?
And in some ways, that fact
that anything can be done
and that everybody has a camera
in every community at any moment,
you're not going to be the first
one with the camera at a scene.
So, what do you want to do about the
fact that you can make a picture?
And how deep do you want to go?
In some ways it liberates
us from doing surveys.
I don't mean that literally, survey
projects, but it liberates us
from having to go far and wide.
Because there's people out there
far and wide, that can do it
with their equipment,
with their ideas.
I also fret about this
notion of what will last.
Doug Boyd, very eloquently
told about the challenges just
of the preservation and
access of something as simple
as a cardboard box full of
cassette tapes, analog tapes.
You know, whether to
transcribe or not.
How long it takes to digitize,
all those kinds of things.
And so, when you add to
that the great proliferation
of expressive material that
digital technology brings.
And there are projects that
are sort of like story core,
that sort of anticipate
that, and wire it in.
But there are other times
and there are other places
where that's not really possible.
So, the robust proliferation creates
a real problem of preservation
and privilege, and perpetual care.
The term that they
use in the cemeteries,
but it's just as relevant
to what we do.
You know, how do small grassroots
community-based organizations
or institutions, or families
for that matter, care for
and ensure the lasting existence
of everyday digital documents.
The answer I often get is the
Cloud , which is you know,
if you think about it is a metaphor,
it's really not much of an answer.
But it is somewhat
of an answer I guess.
But those digital documents won't
fit in a shoebox under the bed,
or the corner of a public library
where maybe those Penobscot
photographs were
that are now being
reintroduced to the community
and in the metadata gotten
from community engagement.
Digital files don't wait
patiently to be a restored
like glass plate negatives
or 35-millimeter film
or 16-millimeter motion
picture film, or wax cylinders.
The preservation clock
begins almost at the moment
of conception of the image.
And I worry about that.
I worry about it because
I care about what lasts.
We regularly intervene
in to work to reframe,
and reclaim, and reaffirm ownership.
But if things don't last,
it's very hard to do.
It's very hard to build
that reciprocal loop
that the cylinder project has been
doing for quite a number of years
in different ways, if we
don't have the cylinders.
So, I worry about that.
And I also worry about the, not
that; I've got 2 minutes, so,
and 140 characters right?
Not to worry about, not to make
light of Twitter or posting,
but posting is not a destination.
And neither is sort of
simply mining the web.
It has to be done with
this notion of intent.
And so, I think that when I
talk about fret I want our work
to be distinctive, and because
it is so fragile I want us
to understand how fragile it is.
And that alone should make us
take it even more seriously.
And I think it does.
And I think that's one of the things
we've heard today and yesterday.
Is the fragility of this
material, and of the ideas,
and of the emotions, and of the
ethics is what calls us back
and makes it something
we're drawn to do.
And we should understand that
and play on that, work on that.
Eudora Welty said about
her own photographs,
if exposure is essential, still
more so is the reflection.
And I think it's really
the reflection,
a lot of what we've
been talking about.
And you know how do we
want to reflect on work,
how does work reflect on us?
How can we see ourselves
in that reflection?
And how can we see ourselves with
other people in that reflection?
It's easier than ever
to make the exposure.
But what are we going to
do about it after that
and how are we going to care for it?
How are we going to
make it relevant?
How are we going to look down
and see the word time
[applause], that I'm up.
And that is really I think the
bedrock of what's been talked
about across all these
things from the web
to Native American communities.
>> Thanks to Tom.
I think he's to run
and catch a plane.
But I think he took most
of my time, so that's.
>> Tom Rankin: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And no questions.
>> Elizabeth Peterson: Thanks
to Tom, I think he's got to run
and catch a plane, but also I
think he took most of my time,
so that's also, that was a
good thing, because [laughter].
Well, here we are, we are
at the end of this event.
And as someone said earlier,
I'm not going to say good-bye,
but we will see you again,
and in fact I do want
to invite everyone here if you are
going to be around this afternoon,
to please come by the
American Folklife Center.
We are in the building across the
street in the Jefferson Building.
Staff would love to
see you this afternoon.
We'd love to show you around,
show you our collections.
So, come and hang out with us.
I also want to say please pick
up materials as you're leaving.
Certainly "Folklife and Fieldwork."
If you want some copies of that,
we would love for you to take
that back to where you're going.
And also, just a reminder
that this has been videotaped.
And it will make its way onto
our website in the near future,
not immediately, but soon, soon.
And finally, just a sincere
heartfelt thank you to all of you.
There was so much great
dialogue here.
I think as several people commented,
and certainly as Tom commented a lot
of the issues are about access, but
I think we definitely got to see
that a lot of the work that we're
doing right now is revisiting some
of the work from before.
And these things aren't you know,
just massively, or harkening back
to somebody talking about scale,
and time, and slow archiving.
I think we're probably the
personification of slow archiving,
but I think the last
panel, especially.
I mean looking at how long
that material has been around,
I mean for centuries
in the community.
How the documentation has
evolved, how it's care has evolved,
how the ideas about
access have evolved.
And how it is being reimagined now,
and how it will be
reimagined 40 years from now.
It's a very humbling thing
and I think perhaps some
of the what I've picked
up to day and yesterday is
about kind of right sized access.
I think we have many
different projects here,
they all demand different
care, different approaches,
different solutions about how we
can make this material available.
How we can get people to
engage with it going forward.
And you've given us
a lot to think about.
There's such incredible innovation
going on and we look forward
to having continued
dialogue with everyone.
And so, please keep in touch and
thank you so much, once again,
and thank you for enjoying this
moment and talking about the work
that we're doing for the last 40
years, and for the next 40 years.
So, go forth.
Thank you [applause].
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress visit us at loc.gov.